le beau côté de la crise et que nous
nous sommes permis de vous présenter des
entrevues plus longue avec des penseurs
des chercheurs d'aix juges etc
déjà qu'ils réfléchissent pas seulement
la pandémie mais à autre chose
aujourd'hui c'était le tour de dany
laferrière de l'académie française que
l'on connaît bien ici je les rencontre
et ce mythe
aujourd'hui je suis très heureux
d'accueillir dany laferrière qui est de
passage à montréal ça coïncide avec la
parution de son dernier livre dessiner
je vous le montre mesdames et messieurs
l'exil vaut le voyage avec un escargot
que vous avez dessiné dany laferrière
m'attendais boudani oui je vous entends
je vous entends dernier assourdissantes
je perçois quand même ce que vous dites
que vous allez vous ennuyer et des
chercheurs des penseurs des écrivains se
trouve que cela vous honore monsieur ben
c'est très bien et vous quand vous avez
dit vous ne décidiez par viège pas
d'accord parce que l'escargot que l'on
voit est très jolie les couleurs sont
très belles et est ce que c'est parce
que l'escargot est tellement lente quand
il voyage
il prend le temps de se développer
nouvelle maison à chaque fois il prend
le temps de tisser des liens de
connaître son environnement nouveau et
là il se déplace lentement vers un autre
lieu où il y aura d'autres liens et
d'autres découvertes ces salles
escargots ou c'est un hasard non non non
c'est un magnifique commentaires de ce
livre vous savez dans cette époque où
nous vivons au tout va très vite où il
faut rapidement dire sa pensée on n'a
pas le temps de feuilleter des livres
le temps du hamac de cet ennui des dons
vous parlais tout à l'heure des choses
et réfléchi longuement pensé j'ai pris
l'escargot comme symbole animale précise
et moi parce qu'il arrive toujours à son
lieu d'arrivée
là où il faudrait bien arriver mais il
le fait très lentement en apparence mais
en fait c'est le temps de construire et
sa maison à chaque fois depuis 1976 j'ai
quitté haïti je suis arrivé à montréal
où je vis depuis toujours d'une certaine
manière et c'est ça fait beaucoup
d'années ça fait 40 ans et je suis allé
à miami où j'ai passé douze ans et je
suis à paris depuis que je suis entré à
l'académie française
et ça fait cinq ans et voyez je je
marche je me promène sur la planète avec
lenteur et et à chaque fois je
m'installe dans les pays
je ne suis pas un touriste ne suis
quelqu'un qui habite l'endroit où il
exactement exactement ce que l'on sait
et ce livre n'est pas un livre de voyage
justement c'est un livre sur l'exil
c'est un livre sur tous ces liens c'est
un livre qui donne le goût de lire aussi
parce qu'il ya vous amis que vous nous
amenez hugo bukowski nabokov soit g10
tellement lui c'est l'exil ou si oui
tous les bars etc c'est un peu comme une
sorte de promenade dans ma vie rêvée ma
vie imaginaire et qui est comblée
d'écrivain et ça me rappelle d'ailleurs
mon arrivée à montréal
quand j'ai été cherché à une
bibliothèque de les visages et tous les
écrivains de l'exil puisque c'était ma
nouvelle condition que ce soit au vide
que ce soit hugo que ce soit toussaint
louverture où nabokov qui s'est exilé de
son pays mais qui s'est exilé et cet
écart n'est plus tôt dans une autre
langue la langue anglaise
quand il a écrit son célèbre et lolita
et donc de kim jong il à cette condition
je voudrais une petite parenthèse rien
sur le lit taquet mal compris là les
gens qui ont vu des choses que lui ne
nierai pas mis nécessaire mais bon là
veulent absolument pour nabokov un
berbère ce n'est pas du tout quelqu'un à
suivent et l'hôpital
c'est cette une c'est l'amérique c'est
une forme de célébration de l'amérique
le livre s'est pas uniquement la petite
fille innocente et qui est à l'intérieur
de livres et le cortège de fantasmes et
qu'elle suscite
mais il faut revoir tout le début du
livre lumière de ma vie de mes reins
pour pêcher mon âme elle était lolita
doit cesser c'est un livre de grands
stylistes aussi bon dany laferrière bon
évidemment ça commence en haïti
évidemment et là vous dites vous dit
quelque chose qui m'a surpris moi vous
êtes ça fait 15 ans que je m'informe je
ne m'informe plus à propos des partis
politiques de l'opposition
li certainement du gouvernement je
téléphone plutôt à ma mère et je me
renseigne sur le prix du pain du lait de
l'essence je lui demande
c'est là vu son médecin combien coûte la
consultation et comment va son appétit
ces jours ci l'état de santé de ma mère
n'est pas différent de celui du pays
c'est vrai donc que vous que vous
ressentez ce qui se passe en haïti dans
ce lien avec votre mère et que vous êtes
désintéresser du reste compliquée et
déprimant parfois je suis désintéressé
mais c'est une façon de 10 de parler
aussi et du journalisme
ma mère est une journaliste sa caméra
c'est à dire ses yeux sa sensibilité
mais disent autant qu'on pourrait me
dire que pourrait me dire un journaliste
je me souviens de ce grand éditorialiste
du new york times et kiki et qui
affirmait que les chansons de bruce
springteen disait beaucoup plus sur
l'amérique que la plupart des
commentateurs de la plupart des
analystes aux états unis depuis les 40
dernières années
il disait que ses chansons il parlait
des petites villes américaines des
matins blêmes des gens qui vont au
travail des ouvriers de la vie réelle
ordinaire concrètes quotidiennes
je trouve que j'ai trouvé un moment
donné que quand ma mère me parlait
simplement de ce qu'elle vivait et dans
son microcosme dans son quartier et des
gens qu'elle croise et quand elle me
disait par exemple que la misère avait
avait élargi le terrain le terrain de la
misère s'était élargie et qu'il faut
maintenant on trouvait pas de l'aide
jusqu'à 25 km si on avait faim il faut
aller plus loin que 25 km haute faut
trouver quelque chose à manger personne
ne pouvait plus aidé comme autrefois son
voisin donc la misère avait gagné du
terrain je trouvais que c'était un
commentaire est extrêmement intéressant
et peut être même beaucoup plus
pertinent que les discussions et les
débats politiques qui se faisait entre
les gens du pouvoir
mais malgré tout ça vous déprime pas
parfois de vous constatez que katie a du
mal à sortir de ce bourbier encore ma
mère qui est morte il ya deux ou trois
ans et c'est pas que je ne connais pas
la date exacte mais elle s'installe dans
l'éternité pour moi non je ne contrôle
pas son temps et 2
de disparition encore ma mère qui était
resté toute sa vie en haïti et qui
m'avait dit que j'avais mis en exergue
donne mes livres pays sans chapeau
ma mère n'a jamais quitté haïti parce
que dit elle on ne quitte pas le chevet
d'un grand malade dit ma mère n'a jamais
été déprimé s'il n'a jamais été
découragé
si elle s'était installée dans son pays
et comment on fait dans certains mariage
pour le meilleur et pour le pire
pourquoi moi qui n'ai pas vécu tous ces
malheurs là j'aurai le droit d'être
déprimé on n'a pas le droit d'être
déprimé ce sera la trahison des clercs
la trahison de ceux étions qui ont la
facilité
nous sommes là précisément pour éjecter
de l'énergie à ceux qui sont désespérés
non papou nous désespérer nous mêmes
nous n'avons pas droit cela nous n'avons
pas droit à ce luxe du désespoir parce
que je vis en dehors j'ai rencontré un
jeune haïtien qui m'avait dit un jour
vous n'êtes pas pareil à moi nous ne
sommes plus semblable ça fait 40 ans que
je vis dans un autre métabolisme chaque
nuit je dors avec l'idée qu'on va venir
m'arrêter la musique que j'entends c'est
la musique des bals dérive le coup de
revolver dans la nuit la faim qui me
tenait à y est une fin que vous ne
connaissez plus comment après 40 ans
n'en avons plus de même métabolisme
donc il s'est ainsi pas à moi d'avoir un
jugement n'est d'avoir des sentiments
qui pourrait être désespérant moi tout
ce que j'ai à faire c'est essayer de lui
envoyer des livres qu'ils puissent lire
essayé donné d'essayer de dire aussi
qu'il fait dans la dignité malgré tout
alors dany laferrière est un livre
magnifique qui qui se lit bien malgré
votre vous dites vous écrivez mal je
parle de la calligraphie
évidemment vous avez fait des efforts
par rapport à l'autre paris il son châle
à cette aquarelle premier ça oui c'est
ça le sav de ça faisait si longtemps que
je n'avais pas écrit à la main et ça
faisait si longtemps que mes lecteurs
n'avait pas lu de textes écrits à la
main sauf une courte lettre de leurs
parents ou quelque chose de ce genre
donc que c'est normal que je fasse des
efforts et que je demande aux lecteurs
aussi de faire des efforts lieu quelque
chose qui est écrit à la main et ça
prend
une patience ça prend un esprit
différent ça prend une idée du mouvement
de la lecture qui est complètement
perdue cette lenteur de l'escargot voilà
bravo pour le livre et on va j'ai
commencé je ne lis pas tout les j'ai lu
quelques heures on va ça c'est ça fait
partie des lectures bientôt bruce
springsteen vous avez tellement raison
darkness on the edge of town c'est le
meilleur album de springsteen pour ceux
les plus jeunes ou même les plus vieux
parce qu'après il ya un springsteen qui
a été un peu dérobé par un par un
mouvement qui n'était pas le sien mais
ce disque-là dans knock joss stone est
extraordinaire chaque chanson c'est
l'amérique profonde le new jazz et les
petites villes et les travailleurs bon
dany laferrière vous avez fait un texte
intelligent et touchant sur le racisme
vous dites ça peut sembler lointain les
bateaux négriers mais sur un plan
historique c'était hier les petits fils
d'esclave font tout pour se rappeler ces
siècles sanglant tandis que les petits
fils de colons font tout pour les
oublier comment vous vivez ce débat
actuellement qu'on a ici entre peut-être
cela vous êtes à montréal depuis
quelques jours mais sur le racisme
systémique pas systémiques les plans
d'action que l'on propose à montréal à
québec monsieur trudeau qui lui veut
aller aussi plus loin comment vous
recevez c'est ce que vous trouvez que
c'est sain comme débat là qu'on en parle
et que forcément il va avoir un progrès
à tout ça je pense que c'est très sain
qu'on en parle mais de diot qui va y
avoir un progrès c'est pas que ces
doutes tu peux pas douter du progrès je
n'ai pas droit au désespoir comme je
voulais dit je vis dans un certain luxe
et sociales intellectuelles et presque
matériel dont je n'ai pas droit à ceux
des histoires ni de ce que ça tu
appelles désespérer billancourt c'est à
dire désespérée les ouvriers et les et
les humains qui vous des voix de
l'espoir partout mais je vais simplement
dire que ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'il y ait de telles situations en
amérique
je vais simplement rappelé que le
tremblement de terre de port au prince
qui a coûté 300 mille morts en trente
cinq secondes et qu'on n'en parle plus
puis très longtemps je veux simplement
dire que nous vivons dans une époque où
les informations ou les urgences
remplacent d'autres que l'aco vide avait
remplacé d'autres choses qu'on a oublié
et qui date d'à peine cinq mois six mois
d'autres urgences qui devrait être réglé
et que c'est que cet événement-là ces
événements d'aujourd'hui s'apprêtent
même presque à remplacer l'accord vide
et d'autres pointent à l'horizon
aussi et comme une misère comme comme un
chômage endémique comme des élections et
de trompe en fait toutes sortes de
choses et simplement dire que aussi que
la chose ne se fera pas par le pouvoir
d'après moi le pouvoir est tout à fait
et éjectable dans une société et disons
démocratique
après avoir fait son temps le groupe qui
était au pouvoir doit quand même le cd
ou continuer si possible mais le cd
aussi à un autre groupe
je crois que ce n'est pas là qu'il faut
regarder si l'on veut un vrai changement
c'est pas à la police directement dans
la rue de change et il ne changera pas
parce que c'est pas possible
et il ne fait pas face uniquement à des
gens extrêmement gentil ou à des gens
qu'ils sont innocents et elle fait face
aussi à des gens qu'ils ne le sont pas
alors il ya des réflexes pavloviens dès
qu' on voit quelqu'un on s'apprête à
sortir son arme
si les noirs on saute on sort ces deux
révolvers et on peut tirer de loin parce
que de raison il ya une chance qu'il ait
déjà fait quelque chose de répréhensible
et deuxième raison on sait très bien
qu'on est protégé par le pouvoir
quand il s'agit d'un noir dans le
président de la république des états
unis traite les noirs comme il veut très
par exemple haïti pays où il ya eu cette
guerre d'indépendance de poubelles on
voit très bien que le boss nous protège
la question est on a l'impression qu'on
nous dit on peut y aller donc je n'ai
pas vocation c'est où
oui me dit non je vous dis vous dit ce
n'est pas faux pas regarder vers le
pouvoir
on regarde ou alors chez chacun d'entre
nous absolument on regarde pour moi il
peut pas il faut aller plus haut il faut
aller à ceux qui ont le pouvoir vraiment
c'est-à-dire les intellectuels
dans les intellectuels plutôt la classe
moyenne
la grande classe moyenne noire
américaine qui s'étend est qui et qui
s'intéresse à un grand nombre de choses
dont certaines petites choses très
marginal qui sont la question
amérindienne la question ou des noirs
la question des femmes la question des
gens toutes ces petites choses on la
question de l'écologie
toute cette petite chose qui
s'assemblent et ça mène vers le centre
sera-ce moyenne qui votent c'est elle
qui a le pouvoir
c'est elle qui peut installer un pouvoir
cette classe moyenne croît depuis
longtemps qu'elle n'est pas raciste
c'est là le problème elles pensent que
parce qu'elle n'a pas d'idée raciste
souvent et parce qu'elle n'est pas de
pensée raciste souvent parce qu'elle ne
fait pas d'action raciste elle n'empêche
pas un noir de trouver du travail
elle n'empêche pas un homosexuel de
trouver du travail et elle croit que ces
problèmes là ne la concerne pas c'est
pour ça qu'on elle connaît laisser
littéralement avec les gens qui sont
racistes qui sont sexistes qui sont
homophobes qui sont antisémites et qu'on
se retrouve face à ceux et qui subissent
cette situation là mais de les appeler
la voie à l'intervention des gens
ordinaires qui pensent que ce n'est pas
leur problème
alors que c'est leur problème ils sont
de complicité raciste ouais la review en
plus d'un jardin ni l'algérien je vais
devoir vous laisser c'est tellement
triste parce que si je sui ger ctt et de
l'émission s'est terminée mais il ya
quand même plus de gens dans ces classes
moyennes qui parle de ça aujourd'hui
qu'il y en avait ya trente ans la ba oui
absolument mais il faut aussi quelqu'un
qui ait conscience par seulement qu'ils
ont kg qu'ils en parlent mais il faut
qu'ils aient conscience qu'il sait
trousser renée qui sont au coeur que le
problème ce qui en théorie mais il ne
s'agit plus de compassion il s'agit
d'actions actions dany laferrière c'est
toujours un plaisir
bon séjour à mon là je voulais vous
parler du rising sun je veux savoir si
tu es vrai nina simone 76 tout à fait
vrai
simone avait chanté en tenant un verre
de whisky de la main droite et une
cigarette dans la main gauche et c'est
comme ça que j'ai toujours rêvé décrié a
dit adieu à bientôt
au revoir à bientôt